[Music]
ukraine's president vladimir zelinski
says that investigators have found
evidence of torture among bodies
discovered in a mass burial site in
idiom
440 graves were found days after the
city was retaken from russian forces
let's go live now to al jazeera's hodder
abdel hamid who's in kharkiv you've been
to isiam hodder what did you see there
well certainly i saw devastation and the
grim reality of what war does
to people a city completely desolate i
would say that
every building we walked past by
was at least partially destroyed mostly
were completely
destroyed shard and i'm talking about
civilian apartment blocks i'm talking
about pharmacies banks schools
so it just gives you the intensity of
the shelling that was going in that area
now that
city
has been under russian occupation since
the beginning of march
when they went in there apparently they
found little resistance but the
ukrainians all along knew that it was
very important to get it back simply
because that city basically was a
logistical hub for the russians very
important for their military operations
for resupplying their troops in the
north of the dombas region which is
according to president putin the
ultimate goal of uh this war
now with the war comes also the death
and we went with investigators and
forensic experts to the outskirts of
eziom where they had uncovered a mass
burial site president zielenski the
prosecutors on the ground all told us
that they were already evidence of
torture among some of the bodies
they had so far exhumed but it is a huge
task simply because there are these 440
uh graves according to officials but
some of them could uh carry more than
one person uh so it's gonna it's gonna
take a long time to figure out who are
these people and how they died and as
they are going along with that burial
site well also investigators are looking
for mass graves and they found at least
one which was for a ukrainian soldier
when we spoke an hour ago air raid
sirens sounded there in kharkiv what's
the latest on the fighting
well certainly the the sirens sound in
kharkiv several times per day and
several times uh per night and you do
also see hear loud explosions
nearly uh on a daily on a nightly basis
i would say now this council offensive
has taken everybody by surprise here but
i think one of its successes also has
been that the government has been
not talking about it too much not
publicizes publicizing it until after uh
the facts uh what we do know from the
from the ministry of defense is that
they had pushed further
further east in the northern part of the
country towards the lugansk region there
is fighting ongoing in and around the
town of lissy shank the end game or the
what another
the the end game there would be to get
hands over several donetsk which you
could compare to isium in the sense that
it was another logistical hub it is
another logistical hub
for the uh russians there it also sits
on a very important railway hub and it's
from there they resupply the the troops
that are in the luhans region which is
one of the two
pro-russian separatist self-proclaimed
republics uh so the battle is ongoing
but there's also many other front lines
in this country the deputy defense
minister a few days ago was telling me
there's about 2 500 kilometers of
frontner
around the country and there is there
was this much publicized
counter-offensive in the south of the
country in the gerson region uh many
would say that maybe the ukrainians were
diverting the attention of the russians
by publicizing this counter-offensive in
the south while preparing themselves to
push here in the northeast well from
what we understand and again we're
getting very little information that
effect counter-offensive is going much
slower it's a much different terrain
it's open planes so both sides can see
each other very clearly and it is
slightly more complicated we know that
the ukrainians have managed to put the
russians in a difficult situation in the
sense that they bombed out the bridges
that linked herself to the
crimea peninsula annexed by russia so
they say that at the moment the russian
soldiers there are quite isolated but
this is still the beginning of a very
long battle to retake the country al
jazeera's abdul hamid reporting live
there from kharkiv hello many thanks